Yo what it is? This week haters gonna hate with Othello by William Shakespeare.
One day soulja boy Iago kickin it with some fool named Roderigo when Roddy all like
“Say Iago, why didn’t you tell me my girl Desdemona gone and married Othello? You know I’ve
been tryin to hit that, Iago.” Iago say “Man
f*** Othello. He gave a bump to dat scrub
Cassio when it should be me climbin the ranks.
Plus, I ‘spectin Othello been freakin on
my woman. So fool best watch hisself cuz I’m comin fo him.” Revenge, sucka!
When word come to Dessy’s pappi, he get all up in Othello’s bidness and say “Bitch
did yo black-ass cast a spell on my daughter?”
Othello like “Naw, blood. Ever since I told
her bout all the s*** I’ve seen, she been
ALL up on this.” Desdemona come in and sets
daddy straight, and joins Othello and his
homies to wreck that Turkish army that be
rollin up on Cyprus.
Up in Cyprus, Iago tricks Othello’s number
2 man Cassio into throwin back a lil too much drank.
When Othello see C-dawg actin a fool,
he gives him the boot. But Iago ain’t done messin.
He tell Cassio “Say bruh, you should
hit up Desdemona and axe if she can get Othello
to smoothe things over.”
But on the real, Iago playin dirty. He tell
Othello he best watch his bitch cuz she might
be gettin down with Cassio. Othello ain’t
buyin it at first, but when Iago plants one
of Desdemona’s hankerchiefs in Cassio’s
crib, brutha start wonderin. And Othello get
all turnt up when he sees Cassio goin on about
some woman he playin, cuz Iago make Othello
think C-money talkin dirty bout Desdemona.
After dat, Othello say “Man I’m gonna
ICE that BITCH. Iago. If you my man, you’ll
merc Cassio, son.”
Not wanting to get his hands dirty, Iago convinces
Roderigo to kill Cassio. Even though s***
goes sideways, Iago still comes out on top.
Roderigo can’t snitch since Iago put his
ass six feet deep, and Cassio got a gnarly cut.
Later, Othello rolls up on his woman, and
straight chokes a bitch to death. When Iago’s
biddy Emilia comes in, she like “WHAT THE F***, OTHELLO?” Othello tell her what’s
up, and Emilia immediately calls Iago out
sayin he been lying his ass off. Iago like
“bitch shut up!” And ENDS her.
Man, what is this? The NFL?
Knowin he got played, Othello stabs Iago and then ices himself before the po-po can put him away fo good.
Damn.
Ain’t no doubt dat fool Iago does some dirty s*** up in this play. But as bad as he is,
you can’t deny that brutha do his own thang-
and with style.
Now if you bust open yo copy of Exodus and
slide you bitch-ass to 3:14, you’ll see
dat fool God saying something similar: “I
am what I am.” Like the big G-man, Iago
pullin all the strings up in this heezy. But
also, it’s like Iago dun flipped dem holy
words on they ass. Cuz Iago take good
things, flips em around, and makes em evil.
In fact, that’s how he stir up dat beef
between Dessy and Othello.
Now y’all playas know Willy S never play
it straight, and he’s always blurrin dat
line between good and bad. When Roderigo start
goin off bout virtue, Iago all like:
Now what Iago really sayin is all hustlas
are gardens, and the only one saying what
you gotta plant is yo-self. Not God or anybody
else. You make yourself what you want to be.
Matter of fact, ol Willy got Iago tear down
that holy jive all throughout this play.
Fo example, when Iago tryin to convince Othello
that his woman gettin freak nasty with Cassio,
Othello like “Hell naw B. I got faith my Biddy love me.”
But after showin him the handkerchief and
lurin him to the convo between Cassio and
Desdemona, Iago convince Othello “Man fuck
faith. SEEING is believing, homeboy.” Too
bad Othello don’t know what love is something
you can’t see.
But that’s okay playa cuz you can still
show me love by hitting dat subscribe button.
Catch y’all lata. Peace!